he's Tom Curren NBC sports Boston our
favorite who leads us off this Super
Bowl week what do you make of this that
Brady cut it short after one of the
hosts said something disparaging remark
about Tom's daughter I think it might
have been a straw that broke the camel's
back situation there because he's had a
good back-and-forth with the host there
Kirkman Hannah and Jerry Callahan they
go back and forth was neither of those
guys who made the comment it was a host
apart from them it was an overnight host
who made the comment but I think that
you know they've gone back and forth on
a number of things over the years and
Kirk in particular will push him on
things but I think this was I mean it's
a it's a bridge too far I mean it's just
way over the line when you're talking
about a five-year-old girl in those
terms but he says that he's gonna have
to reassess his relationship with the
station I mean this would be a huge loss
because Brady normally doesn't talk to
the media I mean he'll do his normal
press conferences but that's rare when
he does when he gives you know 30
minutes of his time yeah and he's he's
you can tell that he saves up a lot of
his nuggets and insights for that
interview
you know he'll go further in depth
because it's it's not necessarily he
can't dictate the terms of it because
they do give him good pushback but he
feels comfortable going back and forth
whether it's you know the tv12 stuff or
Alex Guerrero or his diet the things
that are important to him that's where
he gets more expansive you're exactly
right so yep I mean I'm sure you have an
open chair if he decides to go become a
free agent yeah weekly open chair we
have the open chair I don't have the
money to pay him but I have the open
chair well if you take him to Pebble he
can go to Pebble one yes I have the
interview with him it's now been changed
to tonight with Brady ah so this is the
sit-down this will be the interview that
runs in the final 30 minutes of our
pregame show we've talked about the
brady michael jordan comparison because
we knew the media would probably pick up
on it if brady one is six then this
would be the story so we talked about
the story being the story and then then
all of a sudden here we are it got
picked up and everybody started talking
you guys all claiming credit for
hatching this yes
I mean I have to the Super Bowl last
year I said the Michael Jordan is a Tom
Brady of basketball I mean I dated with
a man I did that I was way ahead of the
curve way ahead of the curve so you're
taking credit yeah I mean that's that's
my beat you can't do this to me we did
it okay
yeah we did it got a bigger bugle than
yes exactly we could bugle so you're
gonna say but I had it first bin okay
okay great
I mean what do you want okay so when i
say to brady tonight when i go hey you
know Tom Curren brought this up after
you won last year's Super Bowl of Tom
yeah so if I bring that up to Brady and
then I say hey what do you think of
these comparisons with you and Michael
Jordan I think that he will be exactly
what you said self-deprecating one but
one interesting thing was after that AFC
Championship game when someone asked him
about his hand and whether or not it
affected him he's so aware of what comes
out of his mouth and how it can be
interpreted because remember how he said
the thing about he started to say that
if it affected me but then he said well
we just won the game I don't want to
sound like Tiger Woods say and then I
just won with my C game so he backed off
it so I'm sure he'll be overly
self-deprecating but when you think
about it there's two different ways to
look at it you can say that brady people
will say well Brady doesn't play defense
well Brady if he did play defense he
might have eight Super Bowl wins because
in two of the other ones or seven suit
whether the hell it is he gave him a
lead in 2007 and he left the defense
with a lead in 2011 in both both
instances they burped it up so if he
didn't have he's done all he could to
win every Super Bowl he's been in well
we're not comparing them as far as
athletics ISM it's just accomplishments
because of his athleticism then Tom's
gonna say no I don't deserve to be
mentioned in in any conversation with
Mike he will keep himself behind Montana
at this point I would think because I
just don't think that he takes that
30,000 foot view of himself he really is
still you know in the nuts and bolts and
in the mix of it but he's a competitor
yeah so there's a part of
him that would love to be or compete to
be in that conversation but then there
was the other part of him sort of the
self-effacing public image that's never
going to acknowledge that right and I
think that's what's interesting about
this whole time versus time thing which
I actually find entertaining you know
with a lot of people thought I was gonna
be an infomercial for you know the
business enterprise but you know when
you watch that the main reason he did it
was he wanted to start to create a
record the 2016 season with deflategate
with his mother's illness with the
comeback against Atlanta this Gotham
Chopra had approached him for years
about doing it and then he said you know
what let's let's start to get this stuff
down and I think that when you talk
about the historical importance that he
has to be cognizant of it I think this
stuff right now he is kind of a nod to
that but don't you think that this is
he's his own experiment he he's sewing
everybody that if I can do it you can do
it and to see him succeed at a high
level
maybe the MVP you're in your 40s he's
practicing what he preaches and so the
longer he plays the more he reinforces
what this whole diet this whole you know
what transformation is do you but here's
the thing he's not even an outlier he is
not an outlier playing at 40 I mean
Jaromir Jagr was released yesterday yes
40 frigging 5 man I didn't win the MVP
he didn't win the MVP but he's 45 Manu
Ginobili Vince Carter Drew Brees is 39
Brett Favre had an MVP type season at
the age of 40 what brady is doing is not
unprecedented in terms of being there
yeah but at that position it's a campus
position in all of sports and to play at
that level to be an MVP nobody's ever
been an MB you know that Jerry Rice had
1200 yards at the age of 40 92 catches
12 that's a he's a better athlete than
Tom yeah I mean Joe has a great athlete
we're not talking about we're talking
about the intelligence to stay healthy
to play games
he's only miss games you know when he
had the knee surgery and then he got
suspended but at that position with how
many different makeshift lineups that
he's had and skilled position players
and every
that's gone on in his career it's pretty
remarkable to play this high-level it's
it is remarkable to be at this level to
still be somewhat improving to in
different ways now tell me this then do
you and you kind of mentioned it where
did you come down on this argument
anyway just broach this thing and then
never talk about it no we did who one
who's better um I I don't know if you
can say who's better is great i I do
think it's I think it's one degree out I
come all the way down here I asked one
simple question Michael was in six one
six took two years off would probably
have eight and then it wouldn't be a
conversation so I'll say Jordan is the
best team athlete of the modern era you
can now leave Tom so you allowed in the
one degree he is
so you're downgrading Brady for having
been in two more yeah you lose so going
and losing losing so the Joe Montana
perfect in the Super Bowl is from spray
D that no it does not know I don't know
it just seems like I'm gonna give him in
his world in in the quarterbacking world
to make this many appearances it's not
just the math that we're talking about
here Tom I'm saying Jordan was so great
he gave the Rockets a couple of titles
like that's how nice he was you know
Brady didn't go to the Giants hey here's
a couple of titles that's what Mike did
no it was so great instead Mike was so
great well Tom scored more points than
you don't he's still Tom Curren NBC
Sports Boston and a good friend
no yeah I'm just giving you a it's just
a reintroduction I don't know if you
know what that's like like this big-time
radio here oh it is so so many Tunes in
there gone who's the guy with the accent
and then I say Tom Curren Tom Brady
I can we font him can we put under his
name Tommy Curran Brady nut hugger
let me Tommy Tommy Tommy John where is
the drama from a couple of weeks ago
with the Patriots where is it yeah where
did it go oh no it's still there it's it
exists
honestly you wanna mm-hmm again the
interesting thing about 2017 and 18 is
this Tom versus time stuff is really the
flashpoint it's really kind of what
you're looking at as to why there is a
level of tension and fatigue between
Belichick and Brady it's not that
specifically and it's not Alex Guerrero
specifically but you know after he won
the fifth Super Bowl the Patriots won
the fifth Super Bowl I think Brady said
you don't want to do things a little bit
different I want to try and and get this
out there the the tv12 stuff and what
we're doing so we did a book he did an
app and after 18 years I think he felt
entitled to do these types of things so
he poked his head up and did and
Belichick Sheikh gave a quarterback I
knew it I knew it he's a diva
quarterback now and I think that that's
where do you think Belichick things done
I think that he believes that Tom over
the course of time as needed to be
managed differently than other players
and that it increases over time and that
he gets fatigued from it even if
relative to scores of other players in
the league he's still far less coddled
here's something I didn't understand
from that whole story now we'll never
get the true story at least anytime soon
about why Garoppolo was traded San
Francisco when you could have gotten
more so we can all agree that that still
doesn't sync up correctly right a couple
of aspects don't the over like if you're
gonna keep him for insurance for the
first half of the season
yeah and downgrade him from the first to
a second keep them through the Superbowl
because look how close he came to
meeting a replacement in the AFC
Championship you get the third day so
yes concur but the whole Brady injury
here can you explain how he got 12
stitches if his thumb like which we
tried to recreate sure like I didn't
know how that and I know you asked Brady
after the game hey can I see your
stitches yeah one
- yeah and you nope offered to show of
mine yes but not in that area but it's
super EXTREME pliability din honest to
god that's what it is they kind of chalk
it up to do you really connect give me
FM on just it bent that far and it tore
it do you believe that i I just don't
know the guy to be an outright
bold-faced liar so I've been leaving it
do you believe that I don't I think I
would be terrified if that happened to
me it looks like a horror movie injury
if now we thought now maybe you brought
this up after Brady won his fifth so to
be fair to you you might have brought I
think he gave himself a hand episiotomy
know that he was trying to add a sixth
finger for Super Bowl rings on one whose
guy now you can go with that I don't
know if you brought that up after this I
did not
okay so maybe you could that's one thing
now you're on yeah came up with
something original here maybe you should
bring that up in the interview later
Gronk is not going to be at media he's
not gonna be at media night opening
night okay do you think that that is now
okay first of all orchestrated yeah I
don't think so no I well we have a
conspiracy theory here stagger off the
field next week so you end up in the
concussion protocol protocol you want to
practice he's been in practice twice no
but they're not out of the protocol
thingy okay so we can't answer questions
at the thingy I mean you're right I mean
I would prefer teammates do teammates
not asking questions in practice because
they don't think he can answer them or
they're not sure what answer they're
gonna get that's that's a constant state
with him what happen against
Jacksonville yeah I mean you're in
concussion protocol you can't talk to
the media you can't go to correct is
that what at least that's how they
operate okay I think who's making noise
yeah that's probably Paulie girl right
here we have a theory that it's an easy
way to protect Gronk who's the most
likely to say something off-color
tonight from being there it takes him
out of the equation yeah but I mean he's
done a bunch before he won't screw up
that bed you do Missy
he's so good though Krunk yeah kills me
so funny really I killed me I think he's
great he's gotten better you know just
when he said I see the wheels turning I
wish he had like his head was you know
clear that you could look right in just
seeing these words on an assembly line
coming down ready to go out of his mouth
like oh you know and then there's nobody
there like there's a lifeguard on duty
to grab one of the words and no not
gonna say that there's another guy who
drops super in every every other word
super super excited super competitor
chicks beer yeah
that's growing yeah we'll miss him
tonight he's Tom Curren Patriots insider
Tom Brady nut hugger NBC sports Boston
thank you for brace for element it's
great to see you Tom have a big week and
thank you for all the studio audience
called the den it thank you for all the
contributions that you gave us for the
season we pray thank you yeah see you
pebble thank you buddy for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]